empezó en Orange County, California.
Nosotros éramos los reguladores regionales.
Y nuestros examinadores dijeron,
están haciendo préstamos sin siquiera revisar cuánto es el ingreso del solicitante.
Esto es una locura, debe llevar a pérdidas masivas,
y solo tiene sentido para las entidades involucradas
en estos fraudes de control contable.
Y dijimos, sí, tienen razón,
y sacamos de la industria estos préstamos mentirosos en 1990 y en 1991,
pero solo podíamos lidiar con la industria sobre la que teníamos jurisdicción,
que era ahorros y préstamos,
así que el mayor y peor de todos los fraudes,
Long Beach Savings, voluntariamente cedió sus ahorros federales,
su listado de préstamos, su depósito de seguro federal,
y se convirtió en un banco hipotecario
por la única razón de escapar a nuestra jurisdicción,
y cambió su nombre a Ameriquest,
y se convirtió en el fraude de préstamos más notorio desde entonces.
Sumado a esto, deliberadamente cazaban en las minorías.
Así que una vez más supimos de esta crisis.
La habíamos visto ya antes. La habíamos detenido antes.
Tuvimos señales muy tempranas de ello,
y era totalmente inequívoco, que ningún prestamista honesto
haría préstamos de esta manera.
Ahora veamos la reacción de la industria, de los reguladores,
y de los fiscales de estas advertencias que podrían haber prevenido la crisis.
Empezamos con la industria.
La industria respondió entre 2003 y 2006
aumentando los préstamos de ingreso declarado por más de 500 %.
Estos eran préstamos que hiperinflaban la burbuja
y produjeron la crisis económica.
Para el 2006, la mitad de los préstamos llamados de alto riesgo,
también eran préstamos mentirosos.
No son mutuamente excluyentes,
es solo que juntos son la combinación más tóxica que puedan imaginar.
Para el 2006, el 40 % de los préstamos de ese año,
todos los préstamos hipotecarios de ese año,
eran préstamos mentirosos, el 40 %.
Y esto a pesar de una advertencia de los expertos antifraude de la industria
que dijeron que estos préstamos eran una invitación abierta a estafadores
y que tenían un índice de fraude del 90 %. Nueve cero.
En respuesta a esto, la industria primero empezó a llamarlos préstamos mentira,
a lo que falta una cierta sutileza, y segundo, los aumentó de forma masiva,
y ningún regulador gubernamental jamás requirió o alentó a ningún prestamista
a hacer préstamos mentirosos o a comprarlos,
y esto incluye explícitamente a Fannie y Freddie.
Esto venía de los prestamistas por la receta de fraude.
¿Qué sucedió con el fraude de valuación?
También se expandió bien.
Para el 2007, cuando se hizo una encuesta de valuadores,
el 90 % informó que había sido sujeto de coerción
por parte de los prestamistas para que inflaran la valuación.
En otras palabras, ambas formas de fraude
se hicieron absolutamente endémicas y normales
y esto es lo que creó la burbuja.
¿Qué ocurrió en el sector gubernamental?
Bueno, el gobierno, como les dije,
cuando nosotros éramos los reguladores de ahorros y préstamos,
solo podíamos lidiar con nuestra industria,
y si las personas cedían su depósito de seguro federal,
nosotros no podíamos hacer nada con ellos.
El Congreso, podrá parecerles imposible, sí hizo algo inteligente en 1994,
y aprobó la Ley de Propiedad de la Vivienda y Protección de Valores
que permitió a la Fed, y únicamente a la Reserva Federal,
la autoridad explícita y reglamentaria, prohibir estos préstamos
a cada prestamista, tuvieran o no un depósito de seguro federal.
¿Así que qué hicieron Ben Bernanke y Alan Greenspan como presidentes de la Fed
cuando recibieron las advertencias de que estos préstamos eran altamente fraudulentos
y que estaban siendo vendidos al mercado secundario?
Recuerden, no hay fraude exorcista.
Una vez que empieza como préstamo fraudulento,
solo puede ser vendido al mercado secundario,
a través de más fraudes, mintiendo sobre los representantes y garantías,
y entonces esas personas van a producir
valores respaldados por hipotecas y derivados exóticos
que también están supuestamente respaldados por préstamos fraudulentos.
Así que el fraude avanza por todo el sistema completo,
hiperinflando la burbuja, produciendo un desastre.
Y recuerden, teníamos experiencia en esto.
Ya habíamos visto pérdidas significativas
y tuvimos la experiencia de que las detuvieran reguladores competentes.
Greenspan y Bernanke se negaron a usar la autoridad bajo el estatuto
para detener los préstamos mentirosos.
Y esto fue materia primero de dogma.
Se oponen terminantemente a cualquier regulación.
Pero es también la laxitud de la competencia internacional,
la carrera de fondo, entre EE.UU. y el Reino Unido, Londres, en particular,
y la ciudad de Londres ganó esta carrera de fondo,
pero significó degradar por completo toda regulación en Occidente
en esta estúpida competencia por ser quien podía tener la regulación más débil.
Entonces esta fue la respuesta reguladora.
¿Y la respuesta de los fiscales después de la crisis,
después de USD 11 billones en pérdidas,
después de 10 millones de empleos perdidos,
una crisis en la que las pérdidas y los fraudes
fueron más de 70 veces mayores que en la debacle de ahorros y préstamos?
Bueno, en la debacle de ahorros y préstamos
nuestra agencia, que regulaba los ahorros y préstamos, OTS,
hizo cerca de 30 000 referencias criminales,
produjo más de 1000 condenas, solo en casos señalados como mayores,
y eso minimizando el grado de priorización,
porque trabajábamos con el FBI para crear una lista
de los 100 mayores esquemas de fraude.
Lo peor de lo peor, a nivel nacional.
Cerca de 300 ahorros y préstamos involucrados,
casi 600 altos funcionarios.
Casi todos de ellos llevados a juicio.
Tuvimos una tasa de condena del 90 %.
Es el mayor éxito de todos los tiempos contra criminales de cuello blanco,
y fue por el entendimiento de control de fraude
y el mecanismo de control de fraude contable.
Avancemos hasta la crisis actual.
La misma agencia, la OTS,
que debía regular la mayoría de los mayores préstamos mentirosos
ha hecho -- hoy ya no existe, pero hasta el año pasado,
había hecho cero referencias criminales.
La oficina de contralor de la moneda, que se supone regula los bancos mayores,
ha hecho cero referencias criminales.
La Fed al parecer ha hecho cero referencias criminales.
La corporación federal de los depósitos de seguros,
es suficientemente inteligente como para no responder a esto.
Sin alguna guía de los reguladores, no hay experiencia en el FBI
para investigar fraudes complejos.
No es solo que hayan tenido que reinventar la rueda
de cómo hacer estos procesamientos; han olvidado que la rueda existe,
y por lo tanto tenemos cero procesamientos.
Y claro, cero condenas de cualquiera de los fraudes bancarios de élite,
los de Wall Street, que condujeron la crisis.
Sin experiencia de los reguladores, el FBI formó lo que ellos llaman sociedad
con la asociación de banqueros hipotecarios en 2007.
Esta asociación es la asociación de comercio de los criminales.
Y la asociación de banqueros hipotecarios
tuvo la audacia, y lo logró, de estafar al FBI.
Había creado una supuesta definición de fraude hipotecario donde, adivinen,
sus miembros son siempre la víctima y nunca los perpetradores.
Y el FBI compró anzuelo, línea, plomada, caña, carrete y el barco
en el que salieron.
Así que el FBI, bajo liderazgo del fiscal general, que es afroestadounidense,
y un presidente de EE.UU. que también lo es,
han adoptado la definición de crisis del Partido del Té,
en la que es la primera crisis virgen en la historia,
concebida sin pecado de los alto mandos.
Y son esos peluqueros inteligentes, capaces de defraudar
a los pobres, patéticos bancos, que no tienen sofisticación financiera.
Es la historia más tonta que se pueda concebir,
así que van y llevan a juicio a los peluqueros,
y dejan completamente solos a los banqueros.
Así que mientras los leones rondan por el campo,
el FBI está persiguiendo ratones.
¿Qué tenemos que hacer? ¿Qué podemos hacer en todo esto?
Necesitamos cambiar las perversas estructuras de incentivos
que producen estas epidemias recurrentes de control de fraude contable
que están creando nuestras crisis.
Así que primero debemos deshacernos
de las instituciones sistemáticamente peligrosas.
Estas son las llamadas instituciones demasiado-grandes-para-fracasar.
Necesitamos reducirlas hasta el punto, en los próximos 5 años,
que ya no representen un riesgo sistémico.
Son bombas de tiempo que causarán una crisis global
ni bien fracase la próxima... es cuestión de tiempo.
Segundo, necesitamos reformar por completo
la compensación ejecutiva moderna y profesional,
que es lo que usan para sobornar a los valuadores.
Recuerden, estaban presionando a los valuadores,
a través de todo el sistema de compensación,
intentando producir lo que llamamos una dinámica de Gresham,
en la que la mala ética saca a la buena ética del mercado.
Y tienen éxito, y así el fraude se hace endémico.
Y, tercero, necesitamos lidiar con lo que llamo las tres D:
Desregulación, Desupervisión y la Despenalización de facto.
Porque podemos hacer estos 3 cambios, y si lo hacemos,
podemos reducir de manera drástica la frecuencia de las crisis,
y qué tan severas pueden ser.
Esto no es solo crucial para nuestra economía.
Pueden ver los efectos de estas crisis en la desigualdad y la democracia.
Han producido un capitalismo de amigos, al estilo estadunidense,
en donde las instituciones financieras más grandes
son los principales donantes financieros de ambos partidos,
y esa es la razón por la que, incluso después de la crisis,
70 veces más grande que la crisis de los ahorros y préstamos,
no hay reformas significativas en ninguna de las tres áreas que hablé,
más que prohibir los préstamos mentirosos,
que está bien, pero es solo una forma de munición, para esta arma de fraude.
Hay muchas formas de munición que pueden usar.
Por eso es que debemos aprender lo que los banqueros han aprendido:
La receta de la mejor forma para robar un banco,
para que podamos detener esta receta, porque nuestros legisladores,
dependientes de contribuciones políticas,
no la podrán hacer ellos solos.
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)